I remember the first search engines came
around and back then Alta Vista was a
very big thing.
I'll try to strike a balance between the
inconveniences in terms of advertising
and so on.
They could put on the user and the
utility had for the users,
so it would,
for instance,
mixed search results with advertising
and at this point Google came along.
Google was very small and
inconsequential and nobody really took
it seriously,
but it did an amazing thing.
It did give people exactly what they
wanted.
It give them a pretty much ad free
experience.
I gave them exactly the search result
that they wanted,
the best one's closest ones to what
people wanted to have.
Google dramatically outperformed Alta
Vista,
Altavista disappeared,
and that was an amazing insight to see
that if you are in a dramatically
scalable economy like the Internet for
you have the biggest amount of
competition that you can possibly have.
You need to build a product that is
optimally aligned with the interests of
the users unless you manage to get some
kind of monopoly and can drive out all
the competition.
And so when we build new products in
that space,
we have to think about how to build the
most useful product,
not necessarily just the product that is
going to make the biggest amount of
money that is going to have the most
efficient business model in some sense,
or the best business case.
Eventually it's going to be the product
that is getting the most used by people
and people will find out that they will
use most what is most useful to them in
the long run.
That's going to be the staff that is not
addictive,
hygienic,
that serves the actual needs that makes
them more happy and fulfilled.
And right now we mostly build
applications that utilize the cravings
of people that make them addicted.
People start checking their smartphones
every few seconds to see if a new email
arrived,
but this new email is not going to make
them more happy and fulfilled is instead
it takes survey their attention.
So I believe the next big movement in
how we built technical systems will be
hygienic technology.
It will be how to build systems that is
careful with our attention,
how we use it,
and that is careful of is our way of
living and what we want to achieve is
the tools that we are building.